the coronavirus vaccine is here
absolutely historic
the fda passed an emergency approval of
this
now the first shipment has left a
michigan plant in the middle of the
night
just just like you can picture boxes of
ballots leaving michigan in the middle
of the night
you can picture boxes of this vaccine
heading out
18 275 vials of the vaccine departed the
plant they're headed to all
50 states and president trump very
rightly is bragging about the
accomplishment
i have really good news today our nation
has achieved a medical
miracle we have delivered a safe and
effective vaccine in just
nine months this is one of the greatest
scientific accomplishments in history
it will save millions of lives and soon
end the pandemic
once and for all i am thrilled to report
that the fda has authorized the fisa
vaccine
we have given fisa and other companies a
great deal of money
hoping this would be the outcome and it
was
on behalf of the american people i'd
like to thank all of the brilliant
scientists
technicians doctors and workers who made
this all possible
fisa and moderna have announced their
vaccine is approximately 95
effective far exceeding expectations
totally exceeding expectations it seems
that a cure for our medical
problems is here even though the media
and the left told us it couldn't happen
the cure for our political problems will
be much
much harder to find i'm michael knowles
this is the michael knowles show
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment from friday from
misanthropic perspective says oh man
i don't think kanye is going to win this
i don't know let's hold out hope
i'm not totally sure that kanye is all
out of it but
it does appear that our best wishes for
the presidential election
are slowly seeming less and less
possible president trump got us this
vaccine this is
good news how many people are going to
take the vaccine i don't know but i know
some people really do want to take it
some people are a little leery fair
enough
regardless quite an accomplishment and
it's one that the left in the media told
us could not happen
in fact when president trump would say
that there was going to be a vaccine in
the fall
the media said that's false they would
fact check him
nbc news on may 15th trump said we're
going to get a vaccine
by the end of the year they said fact
check coronavirus vaccine could come
this year trump says
experts say he needs a miracle to be
right
you see trump the idiot he said we'd get
a vaccine by the end of the year all
that
smart experts said that wasn't going to
happen and the media
listening to the experts like we're all
supposed to they said
it wasn't going to happen and then it
did trump
that uneducated person was right
all the experts in the media wrong
september 16th npr
points out that president trump was
contradicting the cdc
when he said you could get a vaccine by
the end of 2020.
so trump that nincompoop he probably
doesn't even have a phd
he was right all those egghead idiots at
the cdc
wrong cnbc on october 22nd this is
quite recent now posted an article with
the headline
president trump says covid 19 vaccine
will be coming by the end of the year
despite contrary evidence well now i've
got contrary evidence to their contrary
evidence
because we did get the vaccine
just one more data point
which we've seen so many of these all
year
that the experts have no idea what
they're talking about
and people with just one little modicum
of common sense
usually know a whole lot more than those
experts despite all of their
many many degrees and who has a
doctorate and who has a phd
and who i think we're all you know the
word doctor means teacher
comes from the latin word for doc doctor
and it comes from the latin verb doterra
so we're all we're all sort of doctors
if we're teaching you things that are
true
much more so than say dr fauci or or all
of these other
experts now president trump is
contradicting the media and the
establishment again not just on the
likelihood of a vaccine but on the
likelihood of
of joe biden becoming president we
discussed on friday
supreme court decision shooting down the
texas case
so texas was going to sue georgia
wisconsin michigan pennsylvania over
election irregularities
supreme court refused even to grant
standing refused even to hear the case
which is too bad they previously had
refused to hear out the pennsylvania
case
where the pennsylvania election
officials very clearly violated the
state constitution by permitting
widespread mail and votes so
just the window of opportunity for
president trump to challenge
biden's certification as president-elect
really really narrowing
but trump refuses to give up hope is it
over
no it's not over we keep going and we're
going to continue to go forward we have
numerous local cases where
you know in some of the states that got
rigged and robbed from
from us we won every one of them we won
pennsylvania we won
michigan we won georgia by a lot we have
a governor a republican governor that's
worse than a democrat he's terrible and
he's hurting kelly and david very badly
the senate
the senators that are terrific people
but
in wisconsin as you know we have a case
going on as we speak and what's actually
going on right now so you have
individual states
yeah we're doing individual studies 14
they're going to certify
the six they transmit what does that do
for you i don't know we're going to
speed it up as much as we can but you
can only go so fast they give us very
little
time but we caught them as you know it's
fraudulent
dropping ballots doing so many things
nobody can even believe it
so there's a little bit of a parallel
narrative going on here and
and i i think the trump team is aware of
this which is
the trump team was told there's not
enough time to get a vaccine out there's
not enough time there's not enough time
and they said we're going to do this in
record time
and stop telling me we can't do it we're
going to do it and they did it
on the vaccine and you hear the same
criticisms of the election lawsuits
there's no more time there's no more
time i mean truly we're down to three
days or something like that
even even less trump still keeping up
this argument now it does not seem
likely
that after the court refuses to hear out
the pennsylvania case which was a very
good case
court refuses to hear at the texas case
court refuses
in any way to become involved in this
election it it does seem unlikely
regardless of what happened in the
voting centers of
atlanta or the voting centers in detroit
or the voting centers in philadelphia we
we have seen evidence of lots of
irregularities
regardless it seems very unlikely that
the electors are going to go and give it
to trump hope they do
hope springs eternal in the human breast
the left wingers
who who are telling you that trump is
upsetting democratic norms are being
completely cynical and disingenuous here
the way i will put it is what i've been
saying now for weeks
it ain't over until the fat lady sings
maybe a week ago you started to hear
that fat lady start to clear her throat
then you started to hear the fat lady
start doing scales to start practicing
the fat lady hasn't sung yet and i'm i'm
unwilling to concede this election
until the electors do vote you just
don't know
for sure with 100 certainty what's going
to happen in the future which is why now
is a better time than ever
to be prepared with long-term
nutritional food options ready wise has
many options including emergency meals
freeze-dried fruits and vegetables for
convenient
on-the-go nutrition ready-wise makes
being prepared
simple and affordable you order online
you get nutritious meals shipped
directly to your door
because right now there is increased
demand because things are a little
unpredictable supplies are limited some
items may currently be out of stock you
should order right now
when government resources are strained
it can be days
if not weeks before fresh food is
available
don't put yourself in that situation
where you need food during an emergency
and you don't have it
prepare today when preparing the
ready-wise meals all you need
four cups of water the water doesn't
even need to be hot you just pour the
food into the water
stir and cover after about 15 minutes
the meal is ready some meals can be
prepared directly in the pouch so you
don't even need additional supplies
for those it's just very important if
you are in any way
conservative lowercase apple uppercase
whatever you want
you want to be prepared for you and your
family this week my listeners can get
free shipping at readywise.com when
entering knowles
at checkout or by calling 855-453-2945
readywise has a 90-day
no questions asked return policy there
is no risk taking the initiative to get
yourself
and your family prepared today that is
r-e-a-d-y-w-i-s-e dot com
promo code knowles k-w-l-e-s to get free
shipping
oh no trump is upsetting constitutional
norms trump
is not conceding the election before he
has to gosh we've never seen this before
we turn now for comment to governor
stacy abrams the woman who lost the
georgia senate race a couple years ago
lost it to brian kemp and yet
has more or less continued to insist
that she's the duly elected governor
of georgia stacy says absolutely no
parallel
between what she and democrats did in
georgia and what trump and the
republicans are doing with the
presidency
first and foremost he has never listened
to what i said i said that the election
was stolen from
the georgia voters because under the
previous secretary of state
brian kemp millions of voters were 1.4
million voters were purged from the
rolls
thousands of voters were denied the
right to vote because of exact match
there were thousands of voters that were
rejected through an absentee ballot and
a provisional ballot process
that was not equal and what he is
complaining about
are the lawsuits that we filed that
successfully fixed those challenges
there is absolutely nothing commensurate
between what i have done
and what donald trump is trying to do
listen carefully to what she says
because stacey abrams
is fluent in political correctness that
is i think her first language i think
that's her native language is political
correctness
so she's using this term she said they
they purged the voter roles
uh because of exact match what is
exactly
oh you mean the the voter has to match
the voter record you know it's got to be
the
legitimate voter the voter has to be
eligible to vote what she's really
saying is
that republicans and democrats have
different methods of stealing
elections the way that democrats steal
elections is they
allow people who are ineligible to vote
to vote
the classic example being dead people
voting
or people who didn't show up to vote all
of a sudden their votes are counted you
saw this in lbjs 1948
senate race in texas which actually
ended up going to the supreme court and
the supreme court
ultimately chose not to hear the case
this
happened in 1960 in illinois when the
daily machine helped steal that election
for
for jfk against richard nixon and you're
seeing that
in certain places here where people who
perhaps ought not to have voted may have
voted you've seen this
for several years so what what
stacey abrams says is look democrats
want more and more and more people to
vote maybe even if they're not totally
eligible to vote
and then the awful republican strategy
to steal elections
is to kick those people off the rolls
all the dead people off the rolls all
the people who lost their right to vote
all the people who
can't prove that they are the person
that they say they are and therefore not
eligible to vote
those aren't both stealing elections one
is protecting the integrity of the
elections
by making sure that only eligible people
can vote and the other one
is packing the ballot box stuffing the
ballot box
when someone who is not eligible to vote
votes that takes away a vote from
someone who is eligible to vote
that disenfranchises people but stacey
abrams is so good at
political correctness yes it wasn't
equal it wasn't equal what does that
mean
it wasn't equal what get a little
specific here darling
well it wasn't equal and that dead
people didn't have the equal right to
vote as
eligible voters obviously president
trump
should keep up this fight until until he
can anymore until the electors actually
certify a winner
and then hopefully you know it's him but
very likely it won't be
and as president trump said at that
white house christmas party then i'll
see in four years
that'll make the media's heads explode
speaking of media lies
and speaking of georgia the media
are lying right now about
this georgia senate race there are two
senators up in georgia both republicans
kelly laufler and david perdue
now now kelly laufler is the one i want
to focus on in particular because i saw
a tweet yesterday
that went up and it was from the hill
the tweet said loffler's campaign
defends
photo with white supremacist and
reported former kkk leader
chester doles i looked at that tweet and
i said
nope that didn't happen that just
obviously didn't happen i would bet
a lot of money that didn't happen so i
click the link
pulls up this article headline
you can't make this up lawfuller's
campaign condemns white supremacists who
appeared in photo
tweet loffler's campaign defends actual
article
loffler's campaign condemns the exact
opposite the lawful campaign never
defended the photograph
with the alleged white supremacist kkk
person this is what they do this is what
the media do
this is why you can't believe them i
know that young
conservatives understand this that you
can't believe a word the media say
but sometimes we need to be reminded of
this that it's not just that good faith
reporters sometimes get things a little
wrong because some of their biases may
be getting
no they're just lying it's it's brazen
it's very often intentional and one
thing i've noticed with
older conservatives boomer and older
conservatives is because
for most of their lives the media were
so subtle about their
biases they they don't believe it so
they'll say yeah
the democrats are terrible yeah we got
to vote for the republicans oh gosh
democrats are taking our country to hell
in a hand basket but they'll still
they've got this residual belief in the
media
they've got this residual idea
that the the media wouldn't just
brazenly lie to you they would
they would and they do all of the time
and you can't
trust them you need to go to alternative
sources and for people who
you know maybe they're 85 years old
they're not the most
computer savvy they don't know where to
find other kinds of
outlets then they'll watch the six
o'clock news and the six o'clock news is
going to lie to them now this over time
it would appear
that that that lock is is shrinking but
in the meantime they could put through
some pretty
radical people right now the the guy
running against kelly laufler
is maybe the most radical political
candidate
that we have seen in recent american
history i'm including aoc in that i'm
including ilhan omar in that
i'm including the whole squad this
guy is extraordinarily radical okay
and it's being totally covered up by the
media
you know uh kelly loffler is a
this seat could determine the control of
the senate
okay this would be this would be a a
real gem to hold on to
and speaking of gems jewelry is one of
the most popular gifts
you can get for the holidays there's
good reason for that
you can rarely go wrong especially if
you're going with the classics
there is nothing more classic and
timeless than fine pearl
jewelry which does not need to break
your budget at the pearl source you get
the highest quality pearl jewelry at up
to 70
off retail prices why because the pearl
source cuts out the middleman
and eliminates the traditional 5x
markups by jewelry stores
sells directly to you the consumer
pearls talk about
a beautiful traditional classic gift
can't go wrong i have bought sweet
little elisa
pearls before pearl earrings and usually
not like a pearl necklace or something
or some other kinds of pearl jewelry
pearl because pearls are very expensive
usually when you go to the store pearl
source cuts that out you will find the
largest selection of pearls available
anywhere and each jewelry piece
is custom made for you customize your
jewelry based on pearl size quality gold
type
length and many more choices the
holidays are fast approaching and
shipping carriers have an unprecedented
amount of volume
do not wait the pearl source offers fast
and free two-day shipping
on every order with zero contact
delivery everything comes beautifully
packaged in an elegant jewelry box
so it is ready to be given as a gift not
sure that you will love your gift no
worries pearlsource has a no hassle 60
day
money back guarantee and with more than
20 years in the pearl business nearly 10
000 5 star reviews
you can be sure that you're getting from
a trusted dealer do not overpay for
jewelry
get 70 off retail prices for a limited
time my listeners can also take another
20
off your order for the holidays the
pearlsource.com knowles
enter promo code knowles at checkout for
20 off your entire order
the pearlsource.com knowles enter promo
code nolescannerwles
at checkout warnock
he's the one running against loffler
take a listen to some of his
ideas for the country i love this pope
he said well i'm not a marxist but i
know a few marxists and they're pretty
good people
so hard to discover and to hear an
authentic vision and voice of authentic
spirituality that gives voice to the
least of these that when it
shows up people describe it as some
strange
ideology rather than the vision of that
poor palestinian prophet who said
that the spirit of the lord is upon me
because god has anointed me to preach
good news to the poor
there's a lot to take issue with here he
opens up
by extolling the virtues of marxism
so i really like this pope because this
pope says that there are some great
marxists out there marxism it's not some
weird
foreign terrible ideology it's great
marxism is basically what jesus is
talking about whom he refers to as
a poor palestinian prophet
i've read many books about jesus
never seen any evidence that he was a
palestinian
jesus of course is a jew
people will take issue with these
bizarre religious rantings but
what he appears to have a religious deal
for is marxism openly could you imagine
this in this country
even 10 years ago an open
supporter of marxism possibly entering
the united states senate
it's unthinkable but
we've opened up a can of worms here i
mean even aoc
doesn't openly espouse marxism
she'll allude to it she'll say i'm a
socialist she'll talk about the green
new deal which
essentially is marxism but to say oh
marxism i love it when people say nice
things about marxism
marxism's so great that's pretty radical
stuff
the reason to vote in georgia president
trump is encouraging people to vote in
georgia even though he's upset with the
governor brian kemp
the reason to vote in georgia is not
necessarily because kelly laughlin and
david perdue are the greatest most
wonderful republicans there ever were
they're fine they're doing a good job
the reason to vote in georgia is
that's the alternative and what's so
scary right now
with the left is that this guy raphael
warnock is extraordinarily
radical in his leftism but even the
left-wing establishment even the people
who would be
considered in the center in the
mainstream of the liberal establishment
or pushing unthinkably radical
ideas i think of somebody like bill
gates does it get more establishment
than bill gates
he is a typical left-wing
billionaire liberal guy who's always
trying to involve himself in public
policy
bill gates was just on jake tapper's
show on cnn why i couldn't possibly tell
you
he was asked about the lockdown what
should happen this remember we had 15
days to slow the spread
back in march now we're 9 or 10 months
later for some reason this is still
going on and
bill gates brought on says well
what are we going to do unfortunately
probably another four to six months at
least
of shutting everything down well
certainly
mask wearing uh has essentially no
downside they're not expensive
bars and restaurants in most of the
country will be closed as we go into
this wave and i think
sadly that's appropriate depending on
how severe it is
the decision about schools is much more
complicated
as a general rule whenever bill gates
has
an opinion about politics you can assume
that the opposite is the thing we ought
to do
bill gates is notoriously infamously
ignorant of political prudence
and the ideas that he does have about
politics are really
terrible i mean wicked bad ideas
now here he just says okay we need to
shut down businesses for another four to
six months because
we haven't put every every small
business out in this country
and so we got another four to six months
that'll really do the trick
since it's too bad but look that's just
what we have to do there's no downside
to wearing masks
there's no i could name a lot of
downsides one we're social animals
uh we're supposed to see one another
it's nice to see a smile uh
we uh are supposed to breathe the fresh
air
uh you can't do that with a mask we're
supposed to speak
one of the uh defining features of
humanity is that we have speech
when you put that mask over you you are
you are literally putting a muzzle on
yourself
now but be because bill gates is a
technocratic liberal
he's not taking political or ethical or
philosophical
uh considerations into his thought here
because he's he just accepts all of the
liberal premises about the world some of
which are contradictory
so he just he just wants to talk about
what works there's no downside
i think there are a lot of downsides to
the masks he's even admitting by saying
that right maybe there's not a lot of
upside that's the implication
but look there's no downside of course
there's a lot of downside one of the
other
downsides of course is that we're told
if people wear the masks we can all
return to normal and i said from the
very beginning that's complete bs
the masks are not going to calm people
down they're going to whip people up
into a frenzy because the masks are a
symbol
that we're in the midst of this terrible
unprecedented pandemic
we've never had masking such as this
before certainly not in our lifetimes
and really not
ever at this scale so just
to see the mask is not to say okay we
can return to normal it's to say
we're not even close to normal and we're
not going to be back to normal until we
take the mask off which i think is a
large part of the
the political symbolism of the masks but
then
he goes a little further it's not just
four to six months and you'll notice a
lot of
big business guys are all for the
lockdowns because the lockdowns have
caused
an historic amount of money to be
shifted from small businesses
to large businesses like amazon apple
all these sorts of online uh google all
these sorts of online companies
but it's more than four to six months it
might be over a year
certainly by the summer we'll be
way closer to normal than we are now
but even through early 2022 unless we
help other countries
get rid of this disease and we get high
vaccination rates in our country
the risk of reintroduction will be there
and of course the global economy will be
uh slowed down which hurts america
economically
in a pretty dramatic way so we'll have
starting the summer about nine months
where a few things like big public
gatherings
uh will still be restricted but
you know we can see now that somewhere
between 12 to 18 months
and we have a chance if we manage it
well to get back to normal
just a quick question i guess i'm a
little confused here who appointed bill
gates
to run all of our public policy for us
why is
bill gates is not saying we should do
this we ought to do this hey i'd like to
persuade my fellow citizens to do this
he's saying this is what we will do this
is what we are going to do
because bill gates is one of these
masters of the universe
who influences public policy in enormous
ways
and he's saying this is what's going to
happen and it's all
for our wellness right it's all
for speaking of wellness for hims.com is
all about men's wellness
if you need help with ed hair loss or
you have a cold if you're interested in
mental health or coven 19 home tests
hymns is here for you through hymns
you can get prescription medication that
treats in particular e.d
real science real solutions to ed kims
makes it easy hims connects you to a
licensed
medical professional online who can
prescribe fda approved prescription
medication to treat
e.d you get the same active ingredient
as that expensive little pill but
without the expensive price tag
this could cost hundreds of dollars if
you had to go through a doctor or a
pharmacy
not so with hims hymns makes it simple
and affordable
you know men don't want to you know talk
about this thing too much
uh no embarrassing conversations no
expensive appointments
just answer a few questions online about
your medical history and a provider will
confidentially
review if approved your medication is
shipped directly to your door in
discrete packaging
shipping is free no more searching
online for answers to questions about ed
or sexual wellness
just go to your hymns account and ask a
medical professional
you can trust try hymns today
by starting out with a free online visit
go to for hymns dot com slash michael
mich ael for your free visit
that is for hims.com michael
f-o-r-h-i-m-s
dot com michael prescription products
are subject to medical provider
approval and require an online
consultation with a medical provider who
will determine if a prescription is
appropriate
see website for full details and safety
information that is for hims.com
michael
bill gates is a great avatar of the kind
of liberal establishment the liberal
political bureaucratic technic
obviously technological entertainment
media establishment the blob
as we refer to it and bill gates is a
key figure in that he holds all the
politically correct views
and they're they're pretty radical you
know he's a dorky guy who wears a
sweater so he doesn't seem that radical
but in many ways his views are more
radical than than even someone like
raphael warnock
in many ways the liberal establishment's
views are more radical than the woke
radicals
there are a lot of crazy conspiracy
theories going around the internet about
bill gates
of course this is according to the media
crazy wild conspiracy theories that bill
gates is interested
for instance in population control that
he
he doesn't want uh p especially in the
third world
uh people to have babies and so he's
going he's very involved
in ways to limit the growth of the
population and i think these
these conspiracy theories are so crazy
in order to believe these kooky crazy
conspiracy theories
you would have to listen to bill gates
himself well the population growth issue
at the global level it's not that
daunting that is
the population percentage-wise is
growing slower today
than in the past and so it
will actually peak out the problem is
that the population is growing the
fastest where
people are less able to deal with it so
it's in the very
poorest places that you're going to have
a tripling
in population by 2050 and so their
ability to feed
educate provide jobs stability
protect the environment and those
locations mean
uh you know they're faced with an almost
impossible problem
northern nigeria yemen chad
and so what we need to do is
take this aid generosity in this
innovation and go into those places
offer the women better tools where they
want to
space birthing or have a smaller family
size
and improve health because it's
amazingly as
as children survive parents feel like
they'll have enough kids to support them
in their old age and so they choose
to have less children this
point of view that bill gates is pushing
is morally abhorrent it is evil it is
wicked
and he's been pushing it fanatically for
decades he is trying to make sure
that there are fewer babies born
specifically fewer little black babies
in africa
and fewer little brown babies in the
third world that's not an exaggeration
he has been foisting abortion on
countries that are traditionally opposed
to abortion
foisting contraception on countries that
are traditionally opposed to
contraception
these ideas of a sort of sterilized
society for a very long time
in 2009 this sounds like something out
of a science fiction movie there was a
secret meeting
held between bill gates george soros i
know we're not allowed to say his name
but
george soros uh oprah winfrey
a number of other left-wing
establishment billionaires warren
buffett was there
you can google it i mean it was a secret
meeting except it did leak to the press
and it garnered substantial press
attention at that time
all of it was designed around this issue
of
overpopulation so we were told
overpopulation is a terrible problem
this is all based on the crackpot
theories of a
scientist a stanford scientist named
paul ehrlich from the 1970s
erlich published a book first in 1968
and then it was republished later on
called the population bomb it said
absolutely the world population now it
was
at that time was around 3.5 billion and
we're going to have mass starvation
mass death in the 1970s and 1980s it's
guaranteed to happen
the only question now is can we
sterilize people and coerce abortions
enough
to to limit some of that misery and
actually advocated
not just getting people voluntarily to
do this sort of thing but
advocated governments coercing that as a
result of these crackpot theories
you had indira gandhi in the prime
minister of india
start tying water and access to
electricity and
access to medical care and and ration
cards to
sterilization so the sterilized
population you had china adopt the one
child policy
which caused upwards of 100 million
babies to be killed
through abortion absolutely wicked some
of the worst atrocities committed in
human history
because of these crackpots stupid
theories which were not true
the scientific expert paul ehrlich who
was a sort of neo-malthusian to use the
technical term referring to a scientist
from centuries ago named malthus who had
the same overpopulation
fascination it just wasn't true
since the 19 late 1960s the world
population has doubled
you go from about three and a half
billion to seven billion or eight
billion or
obviously growing still and world hunger
is at an all-time low
it just didn't happen and these
these moral perverts like like bill
gates and other people pushing this
politically correct moral standard
which is utterly opposed to human life
which says that it to use uh paul
ehrlich's term
that the births of all these babies is a
cancer that needs to be cut out
these guys are pushing this view despite
evidence to the contrary these brilliant
experts
these eggheads these people who are
focused on data in science
and the liberal standard you know i
don't know i mean i'm sure there are
some kind of
actual crackpot theories about bill
gates but you've just heard it in his
own words but he's just i can't imagine
anything worse than that
that is what the scientific
establishment
is telling you and it's because they
maybe they know something or
a thing or two about science probably
they don't guys like paul ehrlich
maintained their professorship at
stanford continued to win lots of
prestigious awards
even though his central thesis was wrong
and led to untold human misery
and they certainly know nothing about
morality or even
a political prudence and the left is
pushing this from the establishment
those are the doctors you know we we'll
be talking about an actual scientific
miracle and achievement coming on monday
december 21st the historical
docu series apollo 11 what we saw will
soon be available exclusively
at dailywire.com this was originally
released as an audio podcast
for apple and spotify what we saw will
be available to watch
as well as listen on the daily wire
apple tv or roku app or at dailywire.com
the docu-series takes a detailed look at
the apollo 11 mission to land a man on
the moon
a dramatically inspiring story apollo 11
what we saw
is a fantastic series to watch with your
loved ones over the holiday break
right now get it for 20 off with code
watch w-a-t-c-h
when you become an insider or above
member over dailywire.com
subscribe make sure to
membership with code downl and access
all of our
wonderful new and existing content head
on over to dailywire.com we'll be right
back with a lot more
the left not just the crazy fringe
radicals but the establishment left
is in the name of science and expertise
and data
pushing a moral and religious and
political vision
that is completely abhorrent that could
should be completely rejected
this is why i often say we need to
strike the word science
out of our public political discourse
because it is used
as a euphemism as a way to sneak in all
sorts of
religious and moral and political ideas
that are really wicked evil stuff
very often the left which is obsessed
with this idea of shrinking the
population being
opposed to human life you you know you
have to have a very contraceptive
society or a sterile society or an
abortive society or
whatever any way to shrink the number of
people who are being
because of global warming we need to
stop having babies
or because of global cooling we need to
stop having babies or because of
overpopulation we need to stop having
babies it's so weird
that the political outcome of it is
always the same even though the
scientific reasoning changes
you had uh aoc pushing the green new
deal radical redistributive policies
a uh suspension of the use of a lot of
energy in the united states
a lot of government control particularly
over health care
the reasoning for the green new deal was
initially global warming
now it seems that the left is is
achieving a lot of the political goals
of the green new deal
but the defense for it is the covid
lockdowns
that they're saying well because of
coronavirus we need to massively
redistribute wealth
we need a major government takeover of
the healthcare industry
we need to suppress the way that people
conduct commerce and the way they
they transport themselves we need to
control people's lives in a way that the
justification changes but the outcome is
often the same
so there was recently an abortion
executive in america
the marketing director at the clinics
for abortion and reproductive excellence
or
care this guy's name is michael
sainz and he shared a photo of the
office christmas tree
being topped with a pair of sofa clamps
these are the clamps that are used to
dismember babies during abortion
and he tweeted out quote it is literally
impossible to top our topper
this is considered science all right
this is considered
not not just beyond the realm of moral
discourse
which sometimes you hear people say look
this is not a religious or political
question this is just science
it's just the facts and so you can't you
can't have ethical concerns about
science because it's just it's science
it's just what it is stop it with all of
your normative thinking
but actually the left goes a little
further they say science is good
right uh abortion is good because it's
it's reproductive health care
we don't need to talk about the ethics
of killing babies for our own
convenience
we're just going to talk about the
science of it all and that's what
they're saying this is this is a good
thing well it's ghastly
obviously anybody who would look at that
would say gosh this
this isn't just a matter of science
that's a little baby who goes in those
forceps
that's not just a clump of cells that
that's built for
the the same issue goes here when the
left says
nobody's pro-abortion we're just
pro-choice now this guy
this sicko michael sainz is
pro-abortion he's celebrating it and
this whole
this whole clinics for abortion and
reproductive excellence organization
is celebrating it on their christmas
tree in a just society
that organization would be shut down and
the people who work for it would be
arrested
and it in a just society
and i think we need to become much more
comfortable having those sorts of
conversations
something has gone seriously wrong
something has been seriously perverted
in our politics if we believe that that
is
morally acceptable or scientific because
it ain't
now speaking of doctors i have to get to
the most pressing issue of the day this
was
went viral over the weekend and you know
since i fancy myself
a doctor for everybody i i need to take
it up there was a very
delightful and funny article in the wall
street journal by this guy joseph
epstein
no relation to jeffrey as far as i can
tell called
is there a doctor in the white house not
if you need
an md and the article says that joe
biden should
think about dropping the honorific which
feels fraudulent
even comic begins madame first lady mrs
biden jill kiddo a bit of advice on what
may seem like a small but i think
is not an unimportant matter any chance
you might drop the doctor before your
name
dr joe biden sounds and feels fraudulent
not to say a touch comic
your degree is i believe an ed d
doctor of education earned at the
university of delaware through a
dissertation with the
unpromising title student retention at
the community college level meeting
students needs
wise man once said that no one should
call himself
doctor unless he has delivered a child
think about it dr
jill and forth with drop the doc there
is some confusion here a lot of people
especially on the left think that jill
biden
is a medical doctor uh whoopi goldberg
famously infamously humiliated herself
on the view
pushing the idea that jill biden should
be the surgeon general of the united
states
i'm hoping dr jill becomes a surgeon
general
joe biden's wife because she's you know
he would never do it but she it's yeah
she's a hell of a doctor
she's an amazing doctor she's a doctor
and phd yeah
i don't i don't know i could be wrong
she's she's a teacher but you know might
might be good for betsy devos's post
oh that's so embarrassing that's because
in whoopi's defense whoopi says it she
should be the surgeon general and all of
those
flapping seals in the audience say yeah
yes yes give us more
give us more of this sort of nonsense
not not one of those people in the
audience who was clapping and cheering
for that
nor did whoopi goldberg for that matter
know what
dr jill biden had expertise in and it's
not even their fault we live in a
culture
that worships at the altar of scientific
expertise
even when that scientific expertise is
rather silly
or seems a little pretentious now i
actually disagree
with the thesis in this article from the
journal even though it's extremely funny
so i still recommend you read the
article
i the word doctor does literally mean
teacher
so i actually i'm sort of i've had this
debate with ben for many years which is
that i think physicians should not use
the term
doctor because they're not doc they're
not teachers usually they're
they're professionals practicing this
this craft i sort of think that only
like
that preschool teachers have more of a
right to use the term doctor than
physicians do neither here nor there
it's a little bit of a pedantic point
i certainly would would agree that it is
silly and pretentious to add this title
doctor if you are jill biden
because you heard in that clip i think
it was behar says
well no i'm pretty sure she has a phd
joe biden doesn't have a phd either
a phd is a a research focused degree
usually for university professors who
are pursuing uh
research in in their field she has
what's called an
ed this is a professional degree usually
for like
high school and middle school
administrators and it just you know
gives you a little bit of a pay bump and
then you can style yourself doctor
i am not uh making fun of people who
pursue these degrees it's a more
advanced degree than i have
i being a bachelor perhaps i should
style myself bachelor michael knowles
sweet little elise would very be very
upset with that
i'm making the point that
to style yourself in this way with a
degree
that would maybe appear to
present you with a more rigorous
education than perhaps you have
is really silly during my entire time in
college
i had exactly one professor who
referred to himself as doctor he was
by far the least impressive academic i
studied with
in college he was by far the most
insecure
and he didn't last very long at the
university all the other teachers went
by
professor or they went by
their first name some many of them went
by their first name
if you got it if you really got it if
you're really confident if you're really
shooting on all cylinders
you don't need to flatter yourself with
these sorts of titles i can't tell you
how many
sort of mediocrities i know have been
posting all over the internet say
darn it i earned my degree i deserve it
i studied
gender studies or sociology or whatever
12 years and i deserve to be called
this it's so pathetic
a little humility goes a long way folks
even if you really did look
i'm a strong defender of the humanities
i frankly i don't really care that much
about the hard sciences
i think conservatives have fetishized
the hard sciences and we shouldn't
because i think a lot of these eggheads
don't know anything and they
they as we were discussing earlier
force on us they slip in all sorts of
religious and philosophical and
political stupid premises
underneath the guise of scientific
expertise and i think that
our idolization of the
hard hard sciences and all these sorts
of things has actually led us to become
politically much less sophisticated
so i forget that i actually i want to
talk to the person with the sociology
degree but just don't be so
pompous about it don't be so prideful
about it just
if you really got it let your work speak
for itself
i'm not i'm not really beating up on
jill biden here even though i think it
is silly that she styles herself that
way
because it leads to confusion and
embarrassing moments for people like
whoopi goldberg
who are trying to defend her but just in
general
the the society has become so incredibly
impressed with itself
is so insistent on all sorts of honors
that people look ridiculous they make
themselves look
absolutely preposterous this this
fetishization of expertise is
really exposing a lot of fools
people like bill gates uh people like
all of those scientific experts
who told that idiot knuckle dragger
trump that we could never get a vaccine
within 2020. guess what we did
all these people really are proving
themselves wrong i think if you if you
really want to be a doctor or a
scientist an expert
have a little dose of humility that's
the beginning of wisdom and then maybe
you could
start to turn the culture a little more
toward wisdom
i don't know that that's going to happen
all those things seem to be in short
supply
and so we're going to have to wait won't
make any too many predictions about what
happens
but we're going to have to wait as we
see these results of the election we'll
see the elector's going to vote
in a matter of days and we'll see if our
problem gets maybe a little bit better
or more likely
much much worse gear yourself up for
a lot of humility i'm michael knowles
this is the michael knowles shall see
tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer
jeremy boring our technical director is
austin stevens
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
production manager pavel vadovsky editor
and associate producer danny d'amico
audio mixer mike coromina hair and
makeup by nika geneva
and production assistant mckenna waters
the michael knowles show is a daily wire
production
copyright daily wire 2020. you know the
matt wall show
it's not just another show about about
politics i think there are enough of
those
already out there we talk about culture
because culture drives
politics and it drives everything else
so my main focuses are
life family faith those are fundamental
and that's what this show is about i
hope you'll
give it a listen
you